I thought we're having I'm sorry I
thought I was invited here to talk about
adult issues I think all the ladies are
being highly offensive disrespectful to
Pearl who's given all of you ladies this
great place
I didn't respect you had that I had a
difference of opinion that's all I think
personally do you feel like we are
disrespecting yeah you guys have been
quite rude a lot of you yeah
it's very offensive right but you can
you can be offended you know you can be
offended and still not over talk people
and and cry and scream into the mic like
sometimes you know I've been offended
plenty of times on shows and I don't you
know over talk people cry and scream
into the mic especially on a show that's
not mine by the way the definition of
misogyny is the dislike contempt you
know and disdain of women so Prejudice
so you basically said exactly what no no
no no
this is the crazy thing and they say I'm
pushing an agenda and yet this is this
is how you act it's a shame it's like
it's a shame Pearl's not getting a Nobel
Peace Prize
I really should I don't know how you do
it you should like honestly that you
deal with this five nights a week peace
it well not anymore at one point I have
another interesting question what's the
meaning of prejudice
ask yourself that no because no don't
come
throw out people
what's the definition of prejudice
you're gonna do it do with me I'll do
bad she's overweight it's like oh the
fat baby mom is gonna talk to me about
being married get out of here get out of
you started you started ma'am yup yup
goodbye I'll see ya okay then please
leave
what up wow wow wow yeah wow
can I say something if you want women to
look good ma'am ma'am ma'am if you want
women to look good please please just
stop talking
everybody
talk about reach oh yeah yeah the fat
the fat baby mama is coming at me okay
her divorce say I don't remember okay yo
you really gotta kick it I don't really
you know I'm just trying to be
okay all right she she came at me first
otherwise I wouldn't have said anything
um
can we get the Nigerian lady to come
back I feel better come back please come
back don't be like this don't be like
this come back
no but don't leave
um
no I respect you okay I respect you just
please come sit down and be polite and
have an adult conversation yeah don't
act like a baby come sit down come sit
out right now come sit out right here
right now when I'm talking to you I'm
talking to you come sit out right now
please hey I'm talking sit down I can't
sit down
are we going
unbelievable no the disrespect the
disrespect of how you talk to me now
after I tell you to sit down
after I tell you to sit I said I'm sorry
to come sit down
that was so disrespectful bro yo
honestly did you guys put up with this
[__] this was bad this isn't
particularly bad that was that was
highly disrespectful it honestly was
just immature Pearl yeah I mean it's
it's so funny she's still filming are we
still even yeah I'm live it's live it's
live you you can come to the front if
you want she talked to me like that can
you come on the sofa do you ever talk to
me like that yeah you can uh what did
you say no no I was oh I was talking to
her but I mean you can if you want to be
on my screen yeah no I was just like we
can come forward yeah I have a feeling
the last woman will be standing today
[Laughter]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible